[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه الكرام هل سيقول هذا العام عام
الفراجات ام عامر
القادمه اعظم على الصعيدين العربيه
والدولي هل سيتحسن الوضع في لبنان او
السودان او سوريا او اليمن او العراق او
تونس او ليبيا او الجزائر او الاردن من
الاوضاع تسير من سيء الى اسوا
اليس هناك سبع عملات عربيه على وشك
الانهيار اليست مشكلتنا الرئيسيه ماليه
واقتصاديه من سيقدم المليارات للدول
العربيه التي تنهار تبعها الم نسمع كلاما
خليجيا يقول لبقيه العرب اقلع وشوقكم
بايديكم لقد ولا زمن المساعدات الم يخرج
علينا زعيم وحزب الله حسن نصر الله وهو
يستجدي دول الخليج كي تدعم لبنان المنهار
الا تتحدث تقارير غربيه عن ان هذا العام
سيكون عام النظام الروسي بقياده بوتن
لكن في المقابل لماذا لا نقول ان القبضه
الغربيه بدات تنهار وان العالم سيتنفس
السعداء كلما ضعفت اوروبا وامريكا لماذا
لا نقول ان روسيا ستنتصر في اوكرانيا
وستفرض نظاما دوليا جديدا سيكون متنفسا
لكل الدول العربيه التي تعاني على كل
الاصعده بسبب الهيمنات الغربيه لماذا لا
نقول ان حلف المقاومه والممانعه انتصر
اصلا على المؤامره الكونيه وهو سيهزم
امريكا والغربه قريبه اليس تصنيفه الحرس
الثوري الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه في اوروبا
دليلا على هزيمه الاتحاد الاوروبي والغرب
عموما امام الاحلاف الدوليه الصاعده اسئله
اطرحها على الاعلام احمد كامل وعلى الكاتب
والباحث العوض
نبدا نقاش بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى
بخيل عوض لو بدات معك
ما الذي يجعلك تتفائل بان هذا العام يعني
سيتطور من سيء الى افضل وليس من سيء الى
اسوا بالرغم من كل ما نراه الان من من
مشاكل وصعوبات وكوارث خاصه على الصعيد
العربي لماذا تتفائل بانفراجات
المشاهدين
معزولين عن العالم العالم
اقل من قريه كونيه كل حدث عكس هناك
تبادليه بالمعطيات وبكل الاحوال احنا
عندنا يعني اقوال ماثوره بعدت عن ظهري
بسيطه عدو عدوه صديقي اذا انفجرت في مكان
تنفرج في امكانيه اخرى الان العالم وغال
2023 ستكون عام 20 سقوط النظام القديم
وليس فقط النظام العالمي للعالم الاندلس
القادمه و ولاده نظام جديد او عالم جديد
وهناك كثير من الكتاب والباحثين
الاستراتيجيين للتحدث عن عالم جديد
هذا العام سيشهد سقوط العالم القديم
انهيار وتداعي العالم القديم
وبذوق العالم الجديد وليس فقط النظام
العالمي»
تفاؤليه انا مش مستعار ومش بس للكلام هذا
يستند الى الف من المعطيات والمؤشرات
والوثائق على الاقل اذا قلنا المعتل الاول
انا امريكا النظام الاندلس اكشوني يعاني
الان من قطبين كبيررين الركود المفرق
والازمات الماليه المفرطه في تاريخ
البشريه عندما يضرب همم نظام اقتصادي ولان
اقتصادي والاقتصاد العالمي للعالم الغربي
عندما يصاب بازمه عنيفه بهذا الحد تبدو
نذر انهيار الاقتصادي الانفجار هذه
الظاهره
الان الان اوروبا وامريكا تعاني من ازمه
حاده جدا في حربها في اوكرانيا ليس هناك
احتمال صفر بالميه ان تخسر الحرب روسيا
وحلفه الاوراسي هي في حاله صعود هي متمكنه
حتى الان ما دمر للقوات الاطلسيه بثياب
القوات الاوكرانيه توازي تسليح 14 جيش ومن
الجيوش الكبرى صوب الطائرات احسب كذا الى
اخره فيها اليوم معنا راح من انهيار لما
يسمى بعالم التكنولوجيا والعالم الافتراض
7.6 تريليون دولار هي خسائر شركات الهيتك
هذه السنه وبهذه واحده من عناصر التفوق
التي كانت امريكا والغرب عندما نلحق بان
الازمه في فرنسا تضربها اخذت حتى النخاع
وهناك تظاهرات شبه اسبوعيه بمئات الالاف
عندما نقرا الى ارقام همم تقول بان
بريطانيا لم تصب بازمه ركود وبازمه تضخم
كالازمه التي تعانيها منذ 60 عاما هذه
كلها معطيات ومؤشرات تفيد ان ذاك النظام
العدواني الذي ركز جهودي وامراه مؤامراته
في المنطقه العربيه لا سيما في العشريه
السوداء لعشر سنوات الماضيه على ما سمي
ربيعاربيه الان هي ما هي مشغوله بازمه
كبيره هي تواجه من قبل اوراسيا وتلل حصاري
سيبدا في منطقتنا وهذا سيخرج المنطقه
جميل جدا احمد كامل العالم القديم ينهار
الجبروت الغربي ينهار الهيمنه الغربيه
تنهار وهذا سيصب في نهايه المطاف في
مصلحتنا كادوه العربيه وخاصه الدول التي
تقف في وجه المشروع الامبريالي
يا سلام
المنطقه المخططه هي محتلينا من زمان شوفوا
كل المناطق الزرقاء دخلت الروسي ويتراجع
يعني
ولم يقف معه حاليا
هل الهند عطيته البرازيل الارجنتين
ايران
المضادات الطائره والطائرات
من 25,000 شوفوا يا جماعه هاي الصوره من
ثلاثه ايام في موسكو
الخارجيه
حاطين عليها مدفعيه
ليش تحط مدفعيه في موسكو هل السلاح
الاوكراني
موسكو حتى اذا في صاروخ وصل لموسكو
انقلاب في اوكرانيا
الدول العربيه
النظام السوري مثلا النظام اللبناني كان
ديمقراطيمقراطي وجهه الخارجي
وكل البشر كل البشر بما فيهم حظرته يتمنى
يروح يعيش في امريكا
انا اعيش في اوروبا وانت تعيش فيها اوروبا
جميل جدا داخليا قبيح جدا
النظام الروسي والنظام الايراني والنظام
الاسد وامثاله قبيح في الداخل وفي الخارج
مين بهذا روسيا مين الحمار اللي بيهاجر
روسيا ايران
لبنان السنه الماضيه 107 لبناني ماتوا
غرقا وهم يهربون من بلدهم من ملايين سوري
من ملايين سوري
برات سوريا واتمن ملايين لاجئ بالف سوريا
وانت بتعرف اذا بتفتح ابواب سوريا بيطلعوا
كلهم
مين يهاجر الى ايران مين يمثل النظام
الايراني نموذجا له فاذا نرجع لموضوعنا في
نظام قبيح خارجيا
وجميل داخليا وفي نظام قبيح داخليا
وخارجيا وهو في ورطه شديده النظام
الايراني في ورطه لا يعلم بها الا الله في
مظاهرات في كل ايران ومحبوسه بنت بنت اخو
ال ال الولي الفقيه اخوه
يعني وصلت النار للحيته لان النظام
الايراني النظام الروسي في ورطه لا مثيل
له يستحيل ينتصر لانه ليش لانه الغرب قال
له ما بدي الغرب 50 دوله من ارقد دول
العالم وبتمثل 75% من اقتصاد العالمي
قبيحه خارجيا هذه
ولكن تقيم نظام انساني داخلها يحفظ كرامه
الانسان
ماذا يبقى لروسيا شو بتصدر نفطه
وهذا الكلام هذا العام اين الى اين
لن ينهار الغرب ابدا وشتويه شوف خليني
افرجيك نموذج على هذا التفكير
تلفزيون السوري شوف التلفزيون السوري
وشوف السوريين هذا اللي عم بقول الحكي شوف
كيف يتدفا شوف
خايف على اوروبا
الحيوانات في سوريا
المنهار مطلقا النظام الروسي يستحيل ينتصر
ثلاث سنين ولن يسقط النظام في اوكرانيا
النظام الديمقراطي وانا سعيد جدا بانه لن
يسقط هذا النظام بالعكس مثل ما فرجيته في
اسلحه في موسكو في خطر على النظام الروسي
وفي خطر على النظام السوري هو همم نظام في
الوجود وفي خطر على النظام الايراني ومن
هب هب هم واللي مثل النظام اللبناني طيب
خلينا نلعب كل الكلام اللي حكام احترامي
الى ما قالوا علاء بالحل او بموضوع على
الاطلاق
عليها بالحديث عن
ايجابي داخليه وسلبيا
من الموضوع هل النظام
والاطلسي جاء بشيء يفيدنا نحن كهرباء هو
من الحرب العالميه
يريد ان يعرف المشاهد العربي
ما هي المؤشرات التي
قول ان سوريا لبنان السودان مصر تونس همم
الاردن ليبيا الجزائر ان هذه البلدان
ستقابل الفرج او امورها ستنفرج هذا العام
اعطيني هل صحيح
عاناته المنطقه والامه العربيه والشعوبها
وهمم الاعلى من ماسي خلال القرن المنصرم
هو بفعل سياسه الغرب وحروبه وتقسيمه
للمنطقه ونهب ثرواتها وتنصيب وتنصيب جماعه
اللبنانيه
لانه بعرفها تمام سوريا دوله استقلاليه
قتلت 40 سنه وصمد
عندما اتحدث بعقلانيه عاليه جدا اذا كان
ريتشارد هاس وكل
الكتاب والاستراتيجيين اتحدثون للكبار
يتحدثون عن نهايه نظام عالمي تميز بالتفرغ
والانجاهيه واضطهاد الشعوب وافتعال الحروب
هذا النظام العالمي عندما ينحاز من
المنطقه ستتوفر للعرب للامم التي طهدت
بفعل سياده هذا النظام فرصه ذهبيه لكي
تستثمر بها وتنهض وتحرر نفسها وتسعى الى
سريعه
على سبيل المثال امثله مباشره كان هناك
مشكله خليجيه وهذه المشكله ايضا بافتعال
امريكي وسعي من اجلها جاريه المصالحه
الخليجيه الخليجيه وانا مؤشر طيب كان هناك
مشكله مع تركيا
كان هناك افتعال لحروب طائفيه ومذهبيه بين
السنه والشيعه وب مئات مليارات الدولارات
كانت بتشبع كل الشعوب وما كان السوري اللي
اعتدي عليها محتاج لرؤوس الحيوانات او
لسواء لا يتدفى انت سوري وانا سوري وبنعرف
سوريا وكان تنكه المازوت فيها ب 700 انت
بتعرفهم في احلى من الطبابيه
لدينا مؤشر الان الحرب اليمنيه
الاخيره وهناك صيغه واتفاقات وممكن ان
تعيد شيء للعافيه
ومناطقنا الاساسيه والمحوريه في هذا
السياق وهذا امر لدينا مؤشر بعوده
العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين والسعوديه وهذا
امر اعلن في سعي لراب الصدا في الحاله
العربيه الان مصر تعاني من ازمه وقد اوقعت
في حبائل دانس صندوق النقل اللي هو ينتمي
الى عالم اللصوصيه وعندما وصلت الى ما هذه
المشكله تجري محاولات لمعالجتها لدينا
الان قرار مصري روسي وقرار روسي بالمصرف
المركزي بالتعامل مع الجنيه المصري
باعتباره باعتباره عمله قابله للتحويل
لدينا الان زياره للسيسي الى الهند ليبحث
عن بدائل لكي لا تبقى المنطقه مجرد
مستعمره
للانجلوسكسون المجرمين الذين زرعوا هذا
القيام الصهيوني والذين افتعلوا هذه
الحروب وجاءوا بالارهابيه من كل قاع
الدنيا وبتلي سوريا وجعلوا سوريا في حاله
الحاجه وليس شيء ان اخر في هذا السياق
جميل جدا
ثلاثه اليها اعلى كامل الامور ذاهبه بهذا
الاتجاه الامور ذاهبه باتجاه الانفراج
وليس الانفجار اعطيني الان مثل ما هو حكم
في جامع لك عنه
عاد امثله عربيه عليه
صوته جميل
ياكل الجو
انا عندي صور
عم بقول لك سوريا سوريا
الخريطه
والتكبير المنطقه وتصغير لا احد لاي علاقه
ثلاث الاف
روسي
المرحله الاولى وعمليه تثبت باكثر من 60
او 70000
سعودي سعودي
يا جماعه سوريا سوريا
753 قاعده عسكريه اجنبيه في سوريا
المنتصره في سوريا الاسد
753 قاعده اذا بدك تفاصيل همم روسيه
وامريكيه وفرنسيه وبريطانيه واسرائيليه
وتركيا 700 ههه
753 قائده اجنبيه في سوريا
هذه الصوره خضعت لتدقيقات لانه مؤسسات
كبيره في العالم ما ادرانين صدقوا انه
حقيقيه
سوريا سوريا
احمد احمد
للاسف
شديدعي
الانهيار العربي يا احمد
اليوم
الليره اللبنانيه بكام اليوم
52,000 54,000 لانه انا الصبح
160 الف دولار الواحد ب 160 الف يعني انا
بصير مليونير في لبنان ب 19 دولار وبصير
مليونير في العراق بسبعه دولار وبسوريا
وبسوريا 7000 يعني اكثر شوي الوضع احسن
بكثير بسوريا بدك على 7000 بدك شيء 50 همم
بتصير
مليونير داخل المواطن السوري 19
والكذب على الناس والدول اللي مالها علاقه
بامريكا انا امريكا قلت لك عملت فينا كل
البلاوي بس انا الي قتلني روسي وايراني
ولبناني من حزب الله دول اعدائي وهدول
اللي يدمروا المستقبل
باربي كثير ولا يوجد ولا مؤشر وانه والله
زيارات وبروك زيت هذا كله كلام فاضي كله
كلام فاضي انا اليوم اريان سعر العمله
اللبنانيه الصبح 50,000 هلا نبيل ما وصلت
على الاستديو 54,000 52 كانت الصبح 52 وين
مؤشرات التقدم
ما في ولا مؤشر تقدم للبنان ولا شعره في
سوريا كل ما بيجيء محمد بن زايد او مسؤول
الاماراتي بتجيب معه فلوس للنظام ارتفع
الليره جمعه جمعه
خلل خطير جدا بتجيء انت بتعطيها
نزلت تتحسنت الليره
بعرف كل صغيره وكبيره
سجل ابره المخدر جمعتين ثلاثه تتحسن
الليره وبعدين بترجع الى السقوط وشوف
المؤشر الليره السوريه هيك
كله هبوط الليره اللبنانيه كله هبوط
الدينار العراقي كله هبوط الجنيه المصري
كله هبوط السوداني العمله ماتت ماتت يعني
السودان
وكل الدول العربيه
هل تستطيع ان تنكر بان مشكله المنطقه
العربيه مشكله العرب الان مشكله ماليه
واقتصاديه بامتياز يعني لا يمكن ان تتحدث
عن اي تحسن في العالم العربي من دون
الكلام عن الوضع الاقتصادي والمالي اعطاك
مجموعه ارقام واحصائيات
كل الوكالات قبل يومين سبع عملات عربيه
الى الانهيار الكامل مصر لبنان سوريا
العراق اليمن ليبيا
تونس تونس وهناك دول عربيه ما راح نحكي
عنا بس اعتقد خلال اسبوعين راح تنضم
للقائمه طيب اذا كان الوضع الاقتصادي
والعمولات تنهار تباعا في العالم العربي
قديمه وليس لها اعلان لبناني
قبل المؤامره ومن بعد المؤامره وما نحن
بسعر موضوع بصير دقيق الكلام
من ازمات اقتصاديه وهي حقيقه وواقعه ولا
احد يتنكر لها لان هي معاشه هي بفعل تامر
ارتكبه هذا الغرب الذي يزول على ما هو
يتراجع وبتراجعه من المنطقه ان تستفيد
الامم التي طهدت وغلبت على امريكا نحن
اليوم كل العمر
ربطها بالدولار
وامريكا التي حمت منظومات حكمت هذه الدول
وقامت هذه المنظومات كما في لبنان
ثروات اللبنانيه بنعبد ودائع اللبنانيه
هذا هذه الحسابات في المصارف الامريكيه
والاوروبيه قيدت هذه الحسابات لان شيع
ومريكه تدير لبنان بس بمفتاح بذريعه من
صدور الكل اللي سرقته لان ما سرقته سرقتوه
بالوكاله عننا اذا هذا الولد الوضع للصدر
له اسباب انا اتحدث عن تراجع الاسباب التي
ادت الى وبالتالي وبالتالي نحن على عتبه
تحولات
ستؤدي هذه التحولات الى الفرق
هذه المنظومه يا صناعه الفرنسيه بلف 1920
تقاسم
المافيا اللي ركبته على الاطلاق تنفض
انفسه الاخيره اللي يعمل القضاء تسكت به
مؤسسه الجيش وغالبا كما يعني تخطط امريكا
واداتهما هو امام حزب الله
لا لا لا لا والله
شريف بقى
يعني بدك قهوه لبناني
هوايتك طيب وهذه العدوانيه غير العقلان هي
محاوله لا شرعي كلامه من اينما اذا عرفه
اكثر منك اعرفها اكثر منك وانا من انخرط
بحرب ثوره 17/02
احمد كامل
احمد عامر
لخصنا بكلامه عم بقول لك الرجل عم بيقول
لك الرجل النظام القديم والهيمنه الغربيه
تتلاشى لبنان سيزدهر سوريا ستزدهر سوريا
135 والان سوريا خارج التصنيف تطلع
بالمائه 195 كانت 35
المستقبل فلوس
خليه كمان
فلوس
بعد ما قتلته الحريري ب 20 سنه
امريكا
العراق العراق
طيب طيب
وشوفوا كيف صارت ولسه راح تصير ابشع ولسه
راحت فيه ابشع طيب لبنان اللي مدمره رخيصه
همم
المانيا
والغاز 100%
طيب كنت ادفع في باريس 100 يورو هلا عم
بدفع 200 وشويه تؤثر عليك ولا مستمر حياتي
وهاي الفتره الاصعب هذا الشتاء هو الاصعب
لانه هو في اوروبا في كل اوروبا لانه هو
القرار الاهم اهم قرار استراتيجي حصل في
سنه 2022 وراح نشوف نتائج 2023 هو قرار
الغرب كله الاستغناء عن النفط والغاز
الروسي الروسي بدك من الجوع مو راح يصير
فيها ازمه داخليه والغرب تجاوز الشتاء
اللي هي المرحله الاصعب يعني
كنت ادفع 100 سنه ادفع 250 بس اللي جاري
راح ادفع 175 لانه الازمه صارت وراءنا
ازمه النفط والوقود في اوروبا وانت بتعرف
نفس الشيء شو تغير على حياتك في بريطانيا
هل انتهيت حقوقك لا هل تغير شيء في حياتك
غير فاتوره اعلى هل تغير شيء اذا اذا على
ضوء هذا الكلام خلينا بالوضع العربي ابو
يقول لك امريكا امريكا الان ام الدنيا الى
صحه التعبير امريكا ذاهبه الى انهيار
خلينا نركز
اثبت قوه فظيعه ما استطاعت روسيا انه تعمل
شيء الغرب كتله وحده بعمره تعرف انا كنت
مراسل للجزيره في حلف الناتو في الاتحاد
الاوروبي سنوات طويله بعرفهم منيح عمره ما
كانت العلاقات الاوروبيه الاطلسيه جيده
مثل الان عمره ما كان التقارب ما بين
اوروبا وامريكا مثل اليوم افضل هو بيقول
لك اختلفوا شوف لوين يعني كل شيء
لم تكن او اوروبا
مين لبى لروسيا مين وقف معه مين وقفنا روس
جميل جدا خلينا لخيل عواد مثلته بدي اسالك
بخيل عوض
نعود الى المساله الماليه والاقتصاديه
انت في لبنان
400 مليار دولار موجودين في الخزائن
الغربيه صح ولا لا ماشي ماشي في سوريا
سوريا
البنك المركزي السوري بشهاده الجميع ليس
فيه دولار واحد مصر الان
مصر الان مصر الان ترى وضع العمله وترى
كيف مصر الاجتماعات كل الاجتماعات العربيه
الان وصندوق النقد الدولي
ماشي همم والله متوقع لي انه الجنيه
السوداني الريال اليمني بده يتحسن الليره
السوريه بدها تتحسن همم السؤال الاخر قبل
ايام وزير المال السعودي
قالها لاول مره وتابعته الكويت في اليوم
التالي ايها العرب
اقلعوا شوككم بايديكم لقد ولا زمن
المساعدات انت تعلم لولا المساعدات
الخليجيه لا في لبنان ولا في سوريا ولا في
امان ولا في السودان كل هذه البلدان الان
كيف كيف عم بتبشر الشعوب العربيه
واحد وخاصه ثاني حسن نصر الله بس دقيقه
حسب نصر الله حسن نصر الله الم يخرج امام
الملايين ويقول يا محسنين يا خليجيين بدنا
كم دولار لبنان ينهار وين اموال شريفه وما
بعرف شو شريفه وينه وينه يا زلمه وجاي
تضحك على اللبنانيين وتقول لهم بده يتحسن
الوضع
حاليا الثالث الاوروبي
يعني فودا عن المنطقه التي كل ابتلاءات
منطقتنا هي بسبب التدخلات تستخرجي»
واستعد جزء من الاموال التي تم لها بها
لبنان ليس بحاجه
لديهم قدرات ولديه الكفاءه والموقع نتيجه
الحسد والطاقه والقوه البشريه ولديه
المغتربين ولديه القدرات المشكله تكون في
هذا السيستم العميل للغرب لبنان
اليمن والسودان ومصر ازماتها بسبب
التدخلات الخارجيه ومحاولات
واذا تراجعت القوه الامبرياليه والسوريه
بس
خليني اسال خليني اسال
خليني اسال عليك
يا احمد يا اخي دقيقه دقيقه سقطا
داخل دقيقه
دقيقه وسنوات
احمد خلص الوقت
كثير سيء فوق التصور وراح نحس فيه ساعه
ساعه
70 للامبرياليه
بينما الامبرياليه نفسها ايه تتقدم تقدم
له اول ما الو اخر وتعيش احلى ايام بخلاف
ما يحلم او اوروبا عنده مشكله النفط
والغاز بدها تحله الخلاله الاشهر وقلت لك
شو هو تاثيرها على الناس وبعدين انحلت
المشكله وراح تشوف روسيا في عنده مشكله
داخليه وفي عنده مشكله اقتصاديه لها اول
ما لها اخر همم اضرب لك مثل طيب
شيء ثاني همم
يا ميخائيل يا زلمه ما حطيتك انت تكلمت
خليه يتكلم
كلمه عليها اعتبار العالم بقدر رموك
الرئيس الفرنسي راح للجزائر الجزائري اهبل
الروسي قال له سوف نقطع لا يمكن نحن نعوض
الغاز الروسي الى اوروبا طيب راح لعنده
الرئيس الجزائري الفرنسي بعد مقابله
ساعتين طلع الرئيس الجزائري وقال سوف نزيد
انتاجنا من الغاز
المصري
والجزائري
اذربيجان قطر
الاخرى هو راح يعوض الغاز الروسي واللي
راح توقع روسيا وقعت عسكريه في ورطه
على سؤالك بالضبط العرب المرتبطين بروسيا
وايران سوداء اسود من اللي كانوا فيها حل
وما في اي مؤشر من رغم كل الكلام اللي عم
يحكي العرب الثانيين اللي عندهم شويه
هزمنا المشروع الامريكي وهيك صار فينا كيف
لو ما هزمناه يا حسره
الامريكي قطر ما راح تعيش ازمه والسعوديه
ما راح تعيش ازمه والامارات وضعت كويس
والكويت الحمد لله في احسن ما يكون وعمان
جيده والمغرب زيد الباقي كله
اول شيء
باختصار شديد
العربي
هو في حاله من التراجع والتراجع الحادث
يمثل الفرصه الذهبيه اذا استثمرنا بهذه
الفرصه نستطيع السيطره على ثرواتنا وعلى
سيادتنا واداره بلادنا وتنميتها ونحن
قادرون اذا فعلنا هذا بان عود نصبح بقوه
محوريه في اعاده تشكل الاقليم والعالم
العالم العالم
من العراق امريكا
[موسيقى]